so good afternoon everyone i'm jeff hare
a professor from across the lake here at
the university of washington i'm very
interested in building tools to help
people explore and understand data more
effectively so let's just start with a
couple examples so here kind of an
homage to Hans Rosling we sadly passed
away this last year here's a scatter
plot of world health and economic
statistics so here along the x-axis of
the scatter plot we see fertility
plotted along the y axis is life
expectancy and then we see countries
represented as individual dots so this
really represents you have a snapshot of
the world in around 1980 but of course
to understand data more effectively we
don't want to see just static imagery
we'd like to be able to interact with it
to understand trends patterns changes
and so on so in this particular example
I might want to see something about the
individual countries so mousing over
this I see the label for Bangladesh but
I also see its trajectory so basically
how is this country moved in terms of
its health statistics over time and I'm
going to do that for other countries as
well such years know Egypt or Bolivia
but I don't know maybe see just the
static capture of these time traces I
want to see how everything moves
together so for example using direct
manipulation I might grab this point and
drag it through time so in this way I
see as Bolivia moves along its time line
I see how the other countries move in
response and in this case you know
backwards or forwards trace out decades
of global development in this case just
using a simple you know tabular data set
there are a variety of visualizations we
might consider of course as we move into
other more complex data types there's
you know a richer array of
visualizations we might use this is a
not very informative visualization
showing you all the different direct
flights across airports in the United
States and obviously in this case
plotting all the data simultaneously
doesn't lead to a lot of insight so in
addition to plotting tools we need to
have a knowledge as to what's going to
make different visualizations more
effective so for example in this case I
might instead use interactivity to show
subsets of the data at a time so in this
case as I mouse around I can see the
direct flights from individual airports
to each other so in this case you know
direct flights from SeaTac to other
airports across the US and as I do this
you might notice that points are
selected just as I mouse near them so we
have to worry about not just the quality
of visual encodings but the quality of
interaction techniques as well
so for example if I double-click I will
show you the hidden visualization this
case AB or annoyed diagram that's being
used to accelerate mouse capture in this
case as soon as I move to a point that
it's the closest to my mouse cursor I
automatically selected that's helping me
more easily select different data points
within this data set I think the real
value from interactivity comes only in
understanding multi-dimensional patterns
so looking at further data about flights
this is over 500,000 slice from the FAA
showing their on-time performance
so this first histogram shows the
arrival delay so how early or late is
the flight the second histogram shows
the local departure time so what was the
clock time the local area when the
flight left and then finally a histogram
of distances and it's useful to look at
these just as univariate summaries
initially to get an overview of the data
so one thing you might notice is that
the mode of this first histogram is
actually negative numbers which is
saying you know basically a bulk of
flights arrive early which may tell you
more about the scheduling practices of
the airlines and their actual you know a
flight time but nonetheless you know
having given given this overview we can
then explore further to see deeper
patterns so for example I might take the
selection region using a technique
called brushing and linking to cross
filter these views so I move this window
around I automatically I just have a
selection irie a granade all the data
and the other plots to see how dependent
different variables are on the selected
view so for example I might say well why
what makes flights late so as I drag out
to the right you know starting from here
I can see how this distribution shifts
and then as I have later in later
flights they're much more likely to
leave later in the day now if you fly a
lot like I do this is probably
unsurprising is that delays can change
so delays early in the day will then
propagate causing flights to be later
and later as the day goes on we can see
that reflected here in this data we
might also ask what allows flights to
arrive early and as we shift to the far
left and see the early in earlier
flights will see a change in the
underlying distribution of the distance
histogram so for example we see that
longer and longer flights unsurprisingly
perhaps are more likely to arrive early
because they have more distance on which
they might be able to make up that extra
time and arrive early and this way you
know we can explore these things both to
get an overview of the data and then
to ask questions that might you know
vary along different dimensions and
interactively gain insights into
multi-dimensional behavior even though
in this case we're only using simple
one-dimensional plots so this is one
instance of what I mean by interactive
data analysis and so to support these
types of interactions I've been working
on visualization tools for a number of
years now so now I'm really over 15
years of work that started with toolkits
written in the Java programming language
such as prepuce then on to flash and
then now it using web-based system so I
the honor of collaborating with my
former Stanford student Mike Bostock for
example on the protists and d3
frameworks we've since been focusing on
the development of higher-level
languages declarative languages for
visualization such as Vega and so one
problem with all of these tools if
you've done much you know for example in
the JavaScript world is that they might
be very powerful but they're also very
verbose so it might be great for
building you know very you know bespoke
visualizations that you might find on
the front page of the New York Times but
fairly unhelpful if you want to rapidly
build a visualization for exploratory
analysis so one important question we
might ask is you know how do we offer
interactive graphics in a way that
allows us to build not just static plots
but interactive exploration tools in the
midst of analysis and so one approach
that we've been exploring - this is a
JavaScript library in a higher-level
language called Vega light this is a
grammar of interactive graphics and so
by grammar what we mean is we have a
closed system that was we have a formal
declarative language for specifying
things like visual encodings but also
interaction techniques that loop back
together this is to support very concise
and rapid specification everything from
you know basic statistical graphics such
as histograms line charts etc but also
to build multi-view visualizations like
we saw in that earlier flight delay
example that not just taking individual
charts and stringing them together
separately but rather having a combined
specification that allows us to bid
multi-view graphics whether it's things
like a scatter plot matrix where we look
at all pairwise projections of a data
set as a set of scatter plots
concatenated and layered views that
might allow us to repeat variables to
see how they differ or faceted views
where we subdivide the data and then
create multiple plots for those
different subsets these are critical
parts of creating effective exploratory
graphics and then we want to add to
these interactions
the first-class citizen of these
visualizations you'd be able to do not
just selections and panning and zooming
those of course very important but also
specified transformations of the data
interactively whether it's re-indexing
data such as in the stock chart panning
and zooming you also create you know
filtered views and then also cross
filtering below as which we saw earlier
so this way we want to be able to
support not just these static plots
again but really rapidly create
interactive graphics and so fortunately
we've had some support in doing this so
we're very honored to partner with jake
vanderplatt and brian granger and
creating altair which is a Python
library for using the vega Lite language
and what I would love to give a keynote
just on all the intricacies of Vega
light and Altair many of others have
already done this so for example my
students gave a talk at open disk off so
if you want to know more about
interactive specification using a
declarative grammar please see that talk
if you'd like to learn more about some
of the motivation from altair you can
say just rewind one year to Brian
Granger's talk here a PI data around
Altair and so while these things are
great and you're excited I actually want
to spend my keynote focusing on a
slightly different question rather than
getting into the nuts of bolts of how to
build a visualization let's pop the
stack and ask our question how might our
tools help us become better analysts
that is getting beyond the nuts in both
of these tools on how they work how do
they function within the larger process
of making sense of data and so one
question that unfortunately it all too
often goes unasked when we talk about
visualization is not how you build that
but rather should I even build that
visualization in the first place how do
I achieve a shin is effective or not so
a starting point for our tour today will
be then to ask the question well what
makes the visualization good let's start
thinking about that and use that as a
foundation from which to think about how
we might start building more powerful
data tools so the start to answer this
question and give you a sense of some of
the research in this space let's just do
a quick experiment I'm going to show you
two shapes your job is to just make a
value judgment how much larger is the
big shape compared to the small shape
don't cheat by using your thumb or a
pencil to measure just make a quick
visual estimate and keep it to yourself
and we'll take a quick poll so first off
here's two circles make a quick estimate
how much larger is the big circle
relative to that smaller circle in other
words how much will you have to magnify
the area of the smallest
our goal to arrive at the larger circle
to raise your hands if you think the big
circle is four times larger all right
well you just look around the room pay
five times larger more six all right
seven now eight nine 10 11 or higher you
okay so what's wrong with your guy's
eyes it's nice that was a very long tail
distribution we got every number four to
11 plus with a you know
so basically we're talking about a lot
of entropy here right so not a lot of
consensus now let's look at a different
example here are two bars do the same
exercise how much larger is the big bar
relative to the small bar so go ahead
and make your visual estimate and we'll
take another poll how many people think
the large bar is four times bigger no
one okay five times you don't see me no
one six okay seven all right eight nine
whoa big drop-off 10 11 or higher anyway
you voted twice so much yes here's you
so obviously already you know a much
tighter distribution you might have
everyone clustered around 6 7 & 8 as
opposed to being spread out between 4
and 11 and a half so in case you're
wondering the answer is the same in both
cases it's 7
so here's no way obviously you have to
melt these circles down to accurately
fill the circle that's 7 here 7 there so
why is this so much easier in one case
versus the other well there's actually
nonlinearities in human visual
processing so the entire research area
of graphical perception dedicated to
trying to study these differences in
what we actually visually decode from
information graphics so for example here
is the results of studies we ran on
using experiments deployed on Mechanical
Turk looking at estimation error for
writing different graphics so we have
bar charts with basically different bars
either either stacked or with distances
between them in terms of position and
length also looking at angle circular
area rectangular area and you see this
fall out and these are showing 95%
confidence intervals of the air and so
by looking at these results we can
actually gain guys
for more effective visualization design
so in this case if I want to support the
task of quantitative comparison so
easily proportional judgments I will
prefer position encodings to area
encoding is as we all just experienced
so we can turn this into sort of
rankings that can be useful for design
so for example given that task of
comparing proportions I can consult
these types of resources or even create
algorithms that use this as a resource
for making informed decisions about
which charts might be better to show in
a given situation so for example here's
a type of map that you might see all too
often this is called a choropleth map
that means it uses color as the encoding
of a state region in this case using a
geographic projection to communicate
some quantity so in this case is data
about political donations and how many
were made in different states so this
case you can see Texas and California
might have given more which probably
isn't surprising because they have a
greater population but other things
might be quite difficult to see so not
only is color a less effective encoding
channels we will you see from those
rankings we also have compounds with
shape you know also sometimes compounds
with projectors that make things even
more difficult to see so things like you
know what happened in yo Delaware or DC
or Rhode Island might be much more
difficult to see due to relative sizes
so for example we might consult these
kinds of resources and say well instead
of using color hue what other visual
channels might I'd like to consider well
x and y are already taken if we want to
keep you know with a map so maybe we'll
instead you know walk up and use
something like areas such as the size of
a symbol to communicate the quantity
instead so in that case we go from this
color map to one using size symbols so
in this case these dark filled circles
basically show the quantities that were
shown in the prior display so in this
case you can see yes California Texas do
have higher values as we saw but DC
actually has a huge number of
contributions that was invisible in the
previous map in addition we actually get
some more latitude for interaction so I
told you the field circles show that
data I showed in the previous map in
this case those empty circles show
totals so those dark circles actually
just showing a subset and we actually
now see set subset relationships by
having symbols within symbols so only
did we gain some more perceptual clarity
we actually gain more degrees of freedom
with respect to showing interactive
selections and how they compare
different states so what to visualize
again is a more important question
overall than like what tool you use to
show it just around this point home I
want to share with you my favorite
example of a perceptual redesign this
was done by Michelle borken and
colleagues while she was a PhD student
at Harvard they worked in collaboration
with doctors at Massachusetts General
Hospital to try and explore different
visualizations of arterial stress so in
the bottom left here us thought was
actually the state of the art display at
the time they started their research
this is an anatomically correct 3d model
of an arterial tract and then color
using a default rainbow color palette to
show you you sheer this is something a
doctor would look at to make diagnostic
decisions for example whether to
administer certain blood-thinning drugs
or an extreme case as part of the
evidence that would go into making an
operation decision and you can see in
these other quadrants here alternative
visualizations so in one case moving
from a 3d model to a 2d model or in this
case you instead represent an artery by
cutting it open and unrolling it and
then ditching anatomic exactness to
instead show sort of topological
connections between arterial tracts the
other design move here of course is
changing the color scheme so for example
going from a rainbow color palette to a
more perceptually motivated diverging
palate that diverges into red for the
areas that are going to be most
troublesome almost worrisome to a doctor
now the real interesting example too
though is what they did when they
evaluated it they actually put this in
front of real doctors with real
diagnostic tasks to see their accuracy
with these different visual encodings
actually quite shockingly to me here's
the result each of which were
statistically significant so you have
with a state-of-the-art visualization of
the time roughly 40 percent diagnostic
accuracy simply changing the color
scheme moved 30 percent up to UM a 71
percent accuracy in this bottom right
and then moving from a 3d display to a
2d display gave you an initial with the
twenty percent boost almost as an
independent factor in improving people's
ability to spot trouble areas and make
appropriate diagnosis with these
visualizations so these different
choices of visual encoding really do
change what we see how easy we see it
and how we make valid comparisons so
knowing something about what makes a
visualization effective you know is
really important because I think most of
you would have you know not have a hard
time deciding which of these displays
they would prefer that their doctor use
right so these they're not just a matter
of intellectual interest they have real
world consequences what we do and don't
see in data so we can use this as a
basis to start to figure out how our
tools might make a slightly better
analyst one might be by providing some
smarts in terms of appropriate visual
encodings we now let's look at you a
slightly broader question given that
foundation and say well how might we
support more effective data exploration
overall so given a new data set that
we're trying to get familiar with we
might have some hypotheses to begin with
but others that might be nascent or
discovered you know as we start to
interact with the data how do we really
make that process more effective overall
well it's a hard question to answer but
one where I think tools can play a role
so just as one example here's a data set
taken from juvenile corrections
department from the state of Maryland
actually from a couple of decades ago
the most important thing to know is that
this is about you know juvenile criminal
offenders who've been processed by the
system and the other most important
thing note that the x-axis is age all
right so as a father of two young
children I can tell you I am very
concerned about the rise in violent
infants so there's clearly you know
something you know maybe it's just the
state of Maryland maybe the West Coast
is different I don't know but as the son
is a wonderful a 95 year old grandfather
- I'm also very worried about these
marauding centenarians about here so as
you may have guessed one of these these
are actually you know data quality
issues in these cases when the age of
some juvenile was unknown different
administrators had different policies of
dealing with the fact that the integrity
constraints on the database did not
allow them to enter unknown as an option
so either opted for zero the minimum or
like the maximum value allowed by their
interface now and that explains a lot of
this data unfortunately I have no good
explanation for you why a 35 year old is
in the middle of this I know maybe there
is particularly baby-faced I can't say
for certain nevertheless data quality
issues are one thing that obviously
undermine exploratory analysis and
something our tools can do a lot to help
us identify but I think I'm more a
deeper and pernicious problems about you
know we might refer to as blinder vision
so after years of teaching visualization
and data science classes a recurring
trend I see they give people an
exploratory analysis project they pick
an interesting data set they have their
candidate hypotheses ready to go and
then they deep dive right into the data
often jumping into multivariate views
without ever assessing simple univariate
summaries without asking what if
questions about what are the ways the
data collection
in an error they might even overlook
latent factors that are actually more
explanatory because they were so focused
on their pet hypothesis and so thinking
about how to make you know exploratory
analysis appropriately broader
comprehensive is another interesting
thing to consider so there are many
pitfalls and analysis I'm sure you if we
brainstormed in this room we could come
up with a very long list so I share just
to write over looking data quality
issues fixating on specific
relationships and of course we know from
with the intelligence analysis and the
psychology literature that we is sort of
limited human beings with you know you
know constrained cognitive capacities
have many other types of biases that
affect what we see and how we think
about things so maybe our tools can play
a little bit of a role in nudging us you
know way towards some of these more
unfortunate tendencies and so that's
actually one thing that we're starting
to explore in projects such as Voyager
this idea like a support you know rapid
interactive analysis of using
visualization but to do so in a way to
also support you being a bit more broad
in your consideration and we all helps
you not overlook certain data quality
issues so let me just go ahead and jump
into a demo of this tool so here's the
Voyager to UI but those of you familiar
with tools like tableau you might notice
some similar elements we have in this
case the data set about cars this is
automobiles over a number of years
different data fields with different
types so we have string data numerical
data its that are laid out here with our
schema and we have visual encoding
channels so if we wanted to we can drag
and drop a variable and make it the
x-axis the y-axis a color encoding etc
all of these which under the hood are
actually being transformed into Vega
light visualizations so as UI is
actually just a way of specifying formal
statements in the underlying Vega light
language but probably what drew you
arrive first is this gallery of
visualizations on the right this part
all we've done is loaded the visual mode
of the data set we actually haven't
specified a visualization we've
automatically populated a gallery of
recommended views so this includes you
know we could be some reviews for each
variable within the data set so that we
can get a quick overview of the shape
and structure of the data so it's
includes you know histograms of all of
our discreet measures and then on to our
technical quantitative measures so in
this case you know we can see you know
some have normal distributions others
look positive
more lognormal in nature and doing so we
hopefully can spot any you know
unexpected values or outliers that might
underlie the subsequent analysis so
looking at this you know I also noticed
that mileage or miles per gallon you
know is one of the properties in the
data set so if I'm interested in that I
might start to build up views on my own
so for example I might grab miles per
gallon drag it to the X field you know
here I get a horizontally oriented dot
plot I can you know it's change the axis
if I wanted to log scale it I could also
just transpose the view now I have it
along the y axis and you notice that
well I've specified a specific focus
view I'm still getting these
recommendations but in this case they're
based on the view I'm currently looking
at so it's actually taking the Vega Lite
specification for this view and then
automatically identifying ways to
generalize that and then present related
visualizations so I might see summary
view such as a histogram or the global
average which in this case is about 23.5
miles per gallon and I also see what
happens when I start adding field
basically in a search frontier what
happens if I look one step forward in my
analysis but do so in a comprehensive
voice I don't overlook potential
relationships of interest so for example
here I see that displacement horsepower
and weight all follow very similar
curves they look rather quadratic in
nature but the relationship between
acceleration and miles per gallon is
quite different so if I want a car
that's fast but also has good mileage
that was built somewhere in this case
between the 70s and 80s it's an old data
set I can see that at the time the top
cars for that those criteria were
Volkswagens there's a VW pickup here's a
you know Dasher and so on so I can see
these outliers that may be of interest
if I'm looking for a fast but
fuel-efficient car as I scroll down I
can see other relationships
automatically as well right I can see
that as the number of cylinders
increases mileage tends to decrease I
can see that you know as an oil only
different origins and it seems like the
USA seems to be creating the least
fuel-efficient cars which you know we
should say is that true or their latent
factors you know that's something we'll
come back to shortly and then finally I
see you notice plotted by time so I can
see that mileage appears to be improving
over the years included in this data set
first I wanted to learn more about that
if I mouse over this icon in the upper
right I actually automatically fill in
and the specification view or what would
be necessary to build this
chart myself so actually scaffold
learning by you seeing examples you can
quickly see how to build it yourself by
looking at this preview I'll go ahead
and click this I'll make this the new
Focus View and then I get
recommendations that are then
conditioned on this being my focus chart
here I see raw data but perhaps I'm
interested in looking at aggregates
instead so this is actually the average
mileage plotted here so maybe I'll
switch to this view instead and then I
see some breakdown by some different
categorical fields so including the
number of cylinders and then getting
back to something we just saw a few
slides ago different origins and indeed
it looks like the USA is doing poorly in
terms of mileage relative to the Europe
up and Japanese markets across time so
let's look at that more closely as well
and as we go to this other view we see
we get alternative visualizations so for
example here I have a line plot with
layers but if I had a lots of series
maybe it makes more sense to break them
off you know in a faceted view so you
see I have alternative coatings
recommended here such as seeing Europe
Japan and USA individually I can also
choose to filter the types of
recommendations I get for example
showing the only things where we add new
categorical fields to the display and
doing so we see a plot here that has the
cylinders broken up into facets and then
includes origin as color and we see that
well indeed the USA does poorly overall
it's also the only region producing
eight-cylinder cars which is sort of by
their nature have worse mileage so more
fair comparison if we're interested in
comparing these different markets would
be to look at the four and six-cylinder
cars we might get slightly more fair
comparisons and not be subject to
ignoring latent factors so in this way
you know we want to explore topics of
interest but also be exposed to the
breadth of the data and this is what the
voyager tool is trying to help
accomplish so going back to the slide
deck you know we ran a study at this and
try to see how people actually change
their data exploration patterns using a
tool like this versus a UI modeled after
tableau and we found was that compared
to these existing tools voyager led to
over four times more variable set scene
so people are seeing a much broader
swath of different multivariate
combinations of their data and they're
interacting with over two times more of
this so it's not just a thing that these
are being rendered on the screen and
ignored people actually engaging with at
least twice as many different plots with
unique data variables driving them
I'm looking at some of the qualitative
feedback people said something like you
know the related view suggestion
accelerates exploration a lot to will
found this really sped up their ability
to get a comprehensive overview of a
data set it also aided learning is that
people study I like that it shows me
what fields to include in order to see a
specific graph otherwise I have to do a
lot of trial and error and can't express
what I wanted to see but we also saw
that maybe these things can in certain
instances work maybe too well in the
sense that you know one person said
these related views are so good but it's
also spoiling that I start thinking less
I'm not sure if that's really a good
thing
so I think this is really interesting
like you know given the scale of data
both not just a number of records but
the number of variables human cognitive
biases some amount of automation can be
really helpful but there's clearly a
delicate balance that if we go whole hog
and sure like automating data analysis
we're going to throw out the baby with
the bathwater and we also run the risk
of people becoming passive receptacles
of what some pre-configured set of
algorithms say rather than driving the
analysis themselves so really having
this right balance between the analyst
and computation within these interactive
sessions I think is critical we're
looking forward to exploring this more
we're further refining the system also
excited to share that we're working with
Bryan Granger and others to try and
bring this as an integrated component
within the nascent Jupiter lab
environment and as we bring both Altair
and Voyager containing these things that
we've been developing largely in the
JavaScript ecosystem but hopefully
making them valuable in the Python data
science world as well and so really
excited to be working on that very
thankful for the collaborations that we
have there but of course all the
examples have shown so far really
focused on visualization and that's not
surprising given how passionate I am but
also how highly developed our visual
senses are it's really a high bandwidth
communication channel nevertheless
visualization is of course just one
component in a much larger process of
data analysis including how we acquire
data clean it up in a great diverse
datasets build models and then also
getting into social functions like how
do we share our results get feedback
disseminate things more broadly and you
know it would be lovely and ideal if we
just you know move from one step to
another and sort of an uninterrupted
flow but of course you know that is a
fantasy and the real world looks
something much more like this as I'm
sure you've all experienced you know for
example visualization is often the
a line of defense against incomplete or
bad data so I visualize something and
realize I might have to acquire new data
sets engage in additional cleaning
there's all these feedback loops that
make the heart of this interactive
process that even if we have automated
machine learning algorithms we're
spending an immense amount of times you
know in human driven feature engineering
model validation and looping etc so
understanding the interactive nature of
actual data science practice is critical
to identifying some of the pitfalls and
making our tools better so to understand
this a bit more broadly my students
collaborators and I also connected the
number of interview studies so here's
one quote that we really like to share
this came from a study we did back in
2012 where data scientists and Industry
said I spend more than half of my time
integrating cleansing and transforming
data without doing any actual analysis
most the time I'm lucky if I get to do
any analysis at all and so I've shown
this quote a lot and every time I do I
get a lot of pushback people have this
quote is just not right
anyone guess why that might be but yeah
exactly so a gentleman yelled out 80% so
everyone's like half this is the
luckiest data scientist I ever met that
they only spend half their time cleaning
up the data and so you know it's like
you know there's maybe at the time when
we first learned earthing that's where
surprises this wasn't you know a bigger
issue in terms of tooling around data
wrangling preparation integration etc so
at the time we felt is something like
the elephant in the room of data science
research you know since then I think the
topic has gotten a lot more attention
but to our efforts and many others is
basically as practicing data science
became more popular and more well known
you know you just couldn't ignore the
magnitude of these issues so that
nowadays we instead have things like Big
Data borat opining in data science 80%
of time spent prepared data 20% of times
spent complain about need for prepared
data right so obviously you know there's
a lot of interaction happening with data
even prior to building models or
creating you know informative
visualizations and so you know that
leads to other questions that we might
try and ask in the realm of interactive
analysis like how might we support
interactive data wrangling this is
something I've been working on now you
know for over a half decade I'll show
you something like I now classic result
of students and I worked on back in the
2011 but before I do I want to show you
the only this isn't just nasty data in
the form of
values or like horrendously designed log
files that you then have to map back
into a table something I like to call
should be structured data it's in some
weird text structure but it really had
no need to be in that weird
idiosyncratic format even sort of well
curated data often has these issues so
for example here's the US taxpayer
dollars at work this is data you could
download from the Bureau of Justice
showing housing crime statistics and
this is designed for human consumption
really in a spreadsheet environment and
nothing else so it's well curated but
you can load it into Excel but if you
try and load this into pandas or into
our data frames or in a relational
database
you know it'll break up on import
because it's just not formatted
appropriately and so to explore some of
these issues we built you know a set of
interactive tools for doing a data
preparation and one of the early
research systems we built was one called
data Wrangler and so I'll show you a
quick demo of that now so here's the
data Wrangler UI using the same data set
we saw in the previous slide of housing
crime data is broken up by different
states and each sort of has its own sub
matrix we've loaded into a tool we see a
somewhat familiar spreadsheet style UI
we see a couple operations have already
been performed that we recognize some
delimiter so we split the data into rows
and columns in this case based on tabs
and I could go on and you know you know
Madge and I had a set of commands like
it you know evoke from a menu that might
be one way to try and clean up this data
we didn't wanted to support you know
interactive transformation we initially
played with a gesture language but we
found our gestures rapidly end up being
ambiguous like the same movement that
someone demonstrates might mean
different things based on context so it
actually took us down more of an
automated recommendation and machine
learning approach so now like I indicate
what I'm interested in
such as in this case I'm interested in
row two what might I do with the fact
that I selected that row well one in
four instances delete that row but I can
also examine the contents I see that row
is empty so the second suggestion here
is to delete all empty rows and doing
that you see I get a visualization which
then highlights what the change to the
table will be if I choose that
particular recommendation
so without visualizing the effect of a
transform of the key part for having
people make sense of this tool so in
this case it does what I want I go ahead
and hit enter and now those rows have
been removed and I can go on with
cleaning up this data my column headers
are actually buried within the data so
I'd like to
extract out that metadata so I click
that row and I get some different
options including the ability to promote
it to a header row so I can go ahead and
do that but of course that was repeated
so I want to get rid of these additional
header rows so I can do that here one
suggestion is to delete these rows
based on exact value matching and that
works in this case so I go ahead and now
I derive which might be kind of a more
complex operation in this chain which is
extracting the state names to make them
part of the data currently they're kind
of buried within this text label so to
indicate my interest in that I'll just
go ahead and select the text Alabama in
the system infers I'm trying to do an
extraction procedure and indeed I am but
you know the initial inferences are
fairly simple in this case matching by
position within the string or by exact
content matching and I can immediately
see in the preview that this doesn't
work for example Alaska is not selected
Arkansas is cut off so I've been wasting
my time with the suggestions I can go
ahead and just start giving it more
examples so that can better you know
generalize inference and now I see that
you know this looks good in this column
and the top suggestion is extract from
the column year after the text in which
also looks very appropriate for this
data set so I can go ahead and enter and
underneath the hood we've actually
learned a regular expression pattern for
performing this extraction now as I'm
doing this you may have noticed some
other features of the display for
example this little numerical icon
indicates that I've inferred that this
is largely numbers and here in red I can
actually select all the things that fail
to parses numbers I'm starting to get
some additional like type safety and
data quality feedback meanwhile over
here in gray is showing me the
proportion of cells that have missing or
empty values and so if I wanted to get
suggestion that what I can do at a
column level I can go ahead and just
click the header and I get some
suggestions which include interpolation
or filling so in this case is actually
filling down you know the empty cells
based on the observed values so in this
case I can go ahead and do that now I
filled out these cells with the state
name and I like to get rid of these rows
I no longer need for example it's a
reported crime in Alabama you know I
could just throw away things that don't
parse those numbers so that could be
brittle in many spreadsheets actually
have you know a value plus an annotation
which might you know break type
inference but might actually be
something I want to keep so to be a bit
more specific say I want to get rid of
the rows that have the text reported
crime in the system initially in furs
I'm doing an extraction based on a text
selection
but I can also give it a hint that I'm
interested in deletions and that helps
you limit the number of different
transformations that might consider and
then here I get you know as my top
suggestion delete all the rows with the
text reporting crime in at the beginning
this is indeed what I want I have a nice
query so I can go ahead and execute it
and now I have a relational data table I
could actually load into any kind of
standard analysis tool sparing you the
minor detail just renaming that column
so at this point I might go ahead and
click export and because this data set
was relatively small it fits in memory
and this browser-based application I can
just automatically omit all of the data
in this case in CSV or TSV or JSON pick
your data format but as I've done this
what we've actually learned as a script
right so this history down here is
actually just a rendering of underlying
programming language statement that we
learned through direct manipulation
interaction so I could use this to
actually cross compile to different
languages so in this initial research
prototype we actually for example
generated Python code that would then
run within a quick and dirty Python
runtime we implemented as a proof of
concept we had since taking this
research so long further and now do
things like generate scripts that will
run at scale you know doing Hadoop jobs
on spark for example so I actually
interactively demonstrated
transformation script get feedback and
then turn that into a program that I
could then execute to run you know at
scale so that was the idea you know
behind things like the data Wrangler
project you know and so since then we've
commercialized this we started a company
called trifecta which releases a free
tool that you can download if you like
called Wrangler that supports a number
of these similar operations this case
you're seeing a data table of
contributions to political campaigns on
the 2016 election cycle in addition to
the table you see histogram so we have
like preview visualizations to aid with
data quality assessment throughout the
way as I demonstrated before you know
interactions like selecting text will
lead to visual previews of possible
transformations but in addition we've
been exploring ways of doing automated
visualization so for example if I come
here instead say given these candidate
names give me a profile this particular
column of my data set and so tell me
things you know like you know
statistical summaries of different
properties of the data of you know type
issues of outliers etc and in this case
for string data to understand what's an
outlier we actually look at the length
of the strings which is a simple that
strangely effective
ristic for actually spotting you know
untoward values in your data set so if I
want to I can actually interact directly
with this visualization so on this box
plot below I can actually select the bar
corresponding to the outliers that are
high and get transformations relative to
those including filtering them out or
isolating them for further analysis so
for example if I elect to keep only the
outline string values representing
candidate names I then get this data
table subset which getting away from
sort of the political morass of today we
can look at what are some of the
candidates you've never heard of who
didn't make it these are all people who
actually have legitimate financial
transactions behind their name that
includes candidates that is basically
the letter A with caps lock stuck press
repeatedly that is you know little what
else do we have in here you know Lindsay
Lohan Emperor Goku who that is
Remo the cutest dog ever the mini
schnauzer from the dog party who else Oh
Alexander soy sauce and taters master
first gourd from the nap party so
there's this whole strange world of
Fringe candidates that had you just been
dealing with this data you know through
symbolic tools you probably wouldn't
have known exists this could have
actually you know maybe you know biased
your analysis in certain ways and with
you might prefer to remove this data or
if you know maybe a journalist maybe
there's a whole interesting story to be
told and investigating what's going on
on these strange fringe candidates who
are actually registered with the Federal
Elections Commission so in this way you
know interaction can also you Megan make
us aware of some of the things we might
have overlooked and so there's balance
between you know human driven
exploration and automation again proves
quite interesting so more generally I
want to say the contrast sort of a
typical approach to data analysis so
might involve things like you start with
a data set you start writing scripts for
transformation and visualization if it's
very large you might also have to then
extract a sample of that data to work
with
you then run your scripts on that data
and then you might visualize the output
so you might you know like map plot live
and create plots based on the output of
having already run this transformation
script and you might you know iterate
etc until you finally arrive at a
suitable set of analysis procedures and
what we're exploring across these
projects both the Voyager and in the
Wrangler projects is is the way to
actually meaningfully invert this
process actually start with visual
representation
of the data whether that's text tables
summary visualizations etc and enable
interactions with those and use that as
evidence to see the search process so
underneath the hood in both cases we
actually have a language model whether
it's languages for representing
visualization or languages for
representing data transformations and
then we actually do search and rankings
so we use a numeration and machine
learning procedures to try and identify
what we think good responses are to what
the users indicated they're interested
in and then closing the loop through
visual feedback whether that's new
visualizations or visual previews of
what transformations would do then
trying to create a technique that's
hopefully faster for experts but also
much more accessible for people who know
their data but aren't necessarily
programming wizards and so that's what
types of things we're trying to explore
and supporting interactive analysis and
so to wrap up I might share just some
some parting thoughts and we need to
explore the sort of space of tools I
know
many of you are avid data scientists
many of you are probably also data tool
builders some of these things might be
things that you consider as you figure
out building tools that people beyond
yourself will be using to conduct
analysis so what are some of the
considerations that we've come across in
this short talk today well one is you
know a careful balance of automation and
control so by using you know you know
automatic recommendations or machine
learning one be able to expedite and
also make broader the process of
analysis but to do so we want to
maintain that control of the analysis
the analyst you know at the center of
this process the resemble as many
pitfalls to automation as I'm sure
you're aware that's like loss of agency
intuition and domain expertise we want
people's understanding of the domain
which vastly typically outstrips just
the data resources you have at hand at
helping guiding and where the analysis
should go what things are genuinely
surprising versus what are just noise
all these things often require human
judgement and if we just black box too
much of this in automated we also run
the risk of putting poor models loose in
the wild which could have devastating
consequences for various organizations
from government industry and certainly
in health as well but of course you know
we as humans have limitations too we
have our cognitive biases we have blind
your vision and we make mistakes so what
are the ways in which these tools can
actually help offset those by having a
better understanding of human capability
is whether it's what makes the
visualization effective or whether
common errors that people encounter and
their reasoning our exploration of data
and trying to think about the design of
tools in ways that help counter
them as I think a critical concern and
so to do that you know what we'd
explored in these projects was enhancing
interfaces with underlying models of
capabilities so what do I mean by models
of capabilities well in this case it was
twofold like to really enable these
applications way to look at the language
level again visualization or data
transformation languages that gave us a
base to formally reason about the steps
the user might take then we think about
within those types of steps you know how
can we rank them or like recommend them
effectively whether it's using you know
visual perception guidelines that help
us pick more effective visualizations or
knowing based on the you know the data
types and relationships
what transformations seem most needed on
at the time now as we build these things
these models that we build to help power
these applications themselves are going
to require curation and so I think an
interesting problem that we're all going
to face going forward is how our
interfaces themselves are going to learn
from us over time and I think data
science is a particularly rich P
tradition to explore these issues I
think we'll have much larger resonance
across many areas of software so how are
these interfaces going to learn and how
are we can help shape them in the most
appropriate way that the models they
learn really do help a larger swath of
people get their job done effectively
and so along the way there's gonna be a
lot of interesting meta challenges as
well so this can require the means to
inspect monitor and audit the models
that are underlying an increasing number
of the interactive sessions that we
experience today and so I think the type
of tools and expertise on there being
explored you know by a community are
going to be critical to these issues
going forward and so be very happy to
engage you all in conversation
afterwards on any of the topics that may
have resonated with you and so with that
I'd like to wrap up I also want to thank
all of my collaborators and students
over the years there's just a small
sampling of them along with different
funding agencies I'd also like to thank
you all in this room my group myself my
students have made immense progress
building on a number of the open-source
tool that the Python community has
developed so thank you for for all that
you produce and all the examples you
provide Thanks
you
[Applause]